are there some of these cases where they
give the diagnosis let's say
schizophrenia
and the people have tried all different
types of medications and
and everything has just hit a hit a dead
end because you got to give some name
for the problem
are there cases of schizophrenia or
whatnot that could possibly be
it is yes it is yes just before three
days
there's one lady she was in the mental
hospital okay she spent about 10 years
uh 10
10 days after this alhamdulillah i asked
allah question the whole
answer is yes the the the question to
ask the whole answer is yes
so i know that you have evil i so after
that subhanallah
i recite quran on her and she fear
relief
and she said this is the first time from
long time if you relief
the medication is not hell i'm not gonna
say everybody have evil eye no
as i said you have to first of all you
have to check yourself with the
quran if you know there is no problem go
to that check yourself with the doctor
yes now what happens if people do you
find some people
reluctant to go ahead and get the
treatment
with the quran what do you do in that
case that's
difficult to help him if he doesn't
believe if he doesn't believe that he
have a problem from evil eye or
from jinny of shaytan i cannot
help him they have to be willing they
have to first of all you have to believe
that the quran is a cure
yeah as a quran okay and if he doesn't
believe oh i don't have ginny i didn't
i don't have uh evil eye i cannot help
him i have to sit him
to sit with him uh to convince him if he
doesn't uh believe
i cannot help him have you had some
people who are not muslims come to see
you and you want help
so what happens in that case where they
they they don't believe
they're not muslim they do not believe
subhanallah and
they when the lady she came girl she
came
and she she told me that i have vedic
the
that lady she have a friend she have an
evil eye
and she you know they share the you know
the experience with between them she
said i went to the imam
and alhamdulillah i'm fine she said i
feel the same
thing so i need help so they both of
them they came to see me
alhamdulillah i told him that there's a
word of allah subhanahu ta'ala
and this is a shifa relief from allah
subhanahu wa
so i will ask allah subhanahu for help
and i will recite quran on you so will
you you will feel
during the the you know the state during
the
the quran and during the uh when i
research quran
you feel headache you feel numbness you
feel sleepy
you feel tired after about our hour and
a half you feel relief
so after our hour and half alhamdulillah
she feel relief she said i feel
alhamdulillah
lighter relief calm even a vision became
clear alhamdulillah
so this is your life yes and after this
alhamdulillah
i give her the quran yeah and i said
please read the quran
alhamdulillah after that she converted
islam oh she accepted this
yes masha allah so what can a
hamdulillah this is amazing to hear
these things what can a person now do
that they can protect themselves what
are some of the things that
you should be doing on a regular basis
yes uh
there is a book this is fortress of
muslim
yes yes yes so this is the the book that
i trust
i believe that uh alhamdulillah uh
everything you need
to protect yourself it's there uh for
example
there's a paragraph morning time
before morning time you have to finish
that paragraph
evening time you have to finish that
paragraph before you sleep
same thing you have to finish the
paragraph before you sleep
when you go to the bathroom for example
say bismillah
allah would become this is
allah to protect me from the female and
male
that's the meaning when you eat say
bismillah
when you sleep when you go inside your
home say bismillah
these things it's not everything of
course everything you have to
always you're going to say oh would it
be like energy okay that's protection
and be aware of to do a haram
salah for example jamaa that's a
protection
dua is a there is a protection now uh
if you do alhamdulillah and you did
the paragraph of from fortress of muslim
now you are protected from allah subhana
tala the whole day
but the question is is that protection
is broke or not sometimes
it is sometimes if you disobey allah
if or you committed any sin that
protection is
cancelled so we have to redo it again
renewal again like astag for allah
alhamdulillah
repeat the names of allah ta'ala after
salah
that is very important after salah you
have to do
like al-kursiy for example
that's like renewal the protection one
more time from the beginning
so the whole dua the book i prefer that
every muslim should have it
okay that's the whole dua it's there
alhamdulillah that you need it
the you need it and that's a protection
yeah you know
don't deal with the haram things don't
listen to the music
because that break your protection don't
deal with the
you know uh the things that allah
doesn't like it
and now especially do you have some
people that come to you and they're not
praying five times a day they don't have
that right that connection that they're
not implementing islam
but then they come to you and what do
you tell them then i mean at the end you
should be living this way of life
from from the creator 24 7. yes
most of the people when they're coming
uh
you know some people they don't pray
yeah
in the beginning i give him like advice
give him like
so you have to follow the quran if you
do not follow the quran the shaitaan
will attacking you
if you do not follow the quran and the
sunna will attack
you too so you have to believe in allah
subhanahu ta'ala you have to
pray five times a day so i give him like
a
small speech about uh how to do uh salah
for example if they don't praise allah
if they do not make wadu they have to to
teach them
i give them some advice a little bit
about islam
you know give them just uh something to
encourage them to
practice islam yeah this is very
important because
in the beginning yeah so if they they
let's say you break that
you get that jinn out of them then they
go back to their old ways
that is another problem yeah most of the
people when they became fine
allah gave them relief they became lazy
they said okay alhamdulillah i'm fine
that's why i have to go
to practice one of these things the
shaitan is attacking
again i know that uh for example if the
patient coming to see me i give him uh
the materials they give him quran quran
you know after like about two three
months he will come back
said uh the promise coming back to me i
said okay the the materials that i give
it to you
the way that i give it to you to to stay
with allah subhanahu wa
not practice he said yes because
praise allah he became lazy to listen to
the quran
became lazy he listened to the music for
example he deal with the
anything is haram so he did not practice
of course
after two three months the pro the the
sentence coming back to him
so we have to practice always okay this
is the reason
yeah so that allah created us to worship
him
exactly yeah so that's how you get the
protection correct yeah
sheikh thank you so much for being with
us if someone wanted to
to get in touch with you do you offer
your services no problem inshallah my
number is uh
my name is my number is uh
two 630-709-53826 three zero seven or
nine
five three eight two do you have an
email or you prefer the
uh mezzanine yahoo dot com yeah mazen
swori
at yahoo.com thank you very much it's
very enlightening inshallah we can have
you back again